Signore Signore non siete per niente
benvenuti a bordo di questo erba Sono di
ritorno al numero della compagnia per la
quale lavoro Vi preghiamo di sistemare i
bagagli a capire senza chiedere il
nostro aiuto se siete seduto in uscita
in emergenza Guai se lasciate anche solo
un casino per terra tutti gli aspetti
elettronici devono essere spente che
sappiamo benissimo che li lascerete
accesi D'altronde se cade l'aereo sono
cazzi vostri per qualsiasi necessità gli
assistenti di volo non sarà una vostra
disposizione abbiamo di meglio da fare
tipo per raccontarci i cazzi nostri
mentre mangiamo gli snack che non
abbiamo voglia di servirvi signore e
benvenuti nell'aeroporto di straccetto e
vediamo di rimanere seduti con la
cintura allacciata e quello lì tutti in
piedi pronti per scendere un classicone
Ci auguriamo che non volerete mai più
con noi e vi auguriamo un terribile
soggiorno